let's go full conspiracy theory here do
you know what it's China you know why
China did I know why I know about the
things they're encouraging they're
sewing racial division a major
vulnerable in our country but they're
also encouraging people to be fat yeah
imagine this a bunch of angry doughy
different races fighting each other and
then China comes to invade and it's just
a big field of fat people going like
well our parents are allowed and China's
like look how pathetic and weak they are
they're buttering us up making us fight
each other Trail Blazer yes thank you
are uncool yes Trailblazer that's the
name that's the name of social justice
warrior look man oh my god there there
there
who was it who said that China had the
right idea was it was it Bill Gates
somebody was talking about social media
censorship I don't remember yeah and
they were like China has the right idea
you don't like that no thanks
China's a horrifying nightmare dude
indeed it is yeah but you know what I
think one of the biggest problems with
Liberty is that you have vulnerabilities
that authoritarians don't have so long
as they find a way to suppress their
population and beat them down without
collapsing they're gonna be the major
advantage you know so like when you look
at kovat China just welded people's
doors shut and then they came back and
found dead dead bodies yeah they don't
care stuff they don't care in the United
States we got civil liberties mm-hmm
well you know it didn't work out too
well for the most part for us but you
can see how the government tried to
suppress to hold us back because it is
an advantage of authoritarian
dictatorship to lock everyone in their
homes and let the sick die whereas here
the individual is paramount so it's a
good thing but there's there's a balance
between security and liberty and we
opted heavily towards Liberty China
security you know they'll that if they
think you're bad they'll just check you
off a building like no way man we're not
gonna risk it
yeah they don't care it was a suicide
yeah yeah no they wouldn't even do that
they would say we killed him because he
was a threat yeah any bike yeah and what
are you gonna say no they post videos of
them torturing people you see the video
of the guy apologize in the cops they're
like why did you badmouth us he posted
on he posted on some social media site
that he thought the cops are dumb and
he's like I'm drunk I was sorry and
like are you ins like yes please please
and they upload the video whenever want
to see it so you know who mark rosewater
is you know who mark rosewater is one of
the lead developers for Wizards and
Magic the Gathering yeah so he held an
event I think it was two days ago and he
always does this on new sets coming out
I'm gonna tease a few cards we can I'm
gonna have a game you can play and you
can try to see you know guess what card
is I'll show you guys so he played the
game hangman you know where you guess a
letter yeah and you mess it up the next
day he apologized I'm sorry I'm sorry it
was it was a terrible idea
I shouldn't have done it it's like what
pathetic what's so confusing absolutely
pathetic yeah there was some woman who
got canceled I guess because 20 years
ago she posted some like offensive memes
or something maybe wasn't 20 years it
was like 10 years ago and she wrote this
long screed if I am so sorry and I learn
every day you know your apology is
worthless they don't care no they don't
they're just a rare as your already
canceled did you imagine apologizing to
the zombie horde coming to eat you
they're like what you're like I'm so
sorry you're hungry I didn't realize
that I smelled so delicious I'll try and
do better and and what is their response
exactly what it's like they don't care
on it there's nothing you can say like
trying to you're trying the alligator
you're arguing with the the the pack of
the the swarm of piranhas coming to
devour your body oh that guy that just
got fired from was the the along he was
the long gated man on flash oh yeah he
had some stupid tweets yes really they
were really gross they were really yeah
yeah but why didn't anyone care then you
know now they're searching you know hunt
no Inquisition yeah you keep saying it
literally Inquisition yeah and then they
keep proving you know what man do you
know what comes next
listen I I talked to my individual
friends and they're like you know I've
been talking a lot of my friends lately
I'm like this is getting out of hand
like they're banning books movies games
it's like a purge statues are being torn
down
they'd effaced Abraham Lincoln and the
response I get is but those are the Bad
Seeds I'm like you [ __ ] people are
literally dying some cops have been
killed you say but those are the fringe
elements there's the they're the ones
who take control after you get your
ideology ideology push through and
Chicago had the most deaths I don't even
know 60s or whatever yeah a single day
it's insane yeah people are getting shot
and they're like but we're the good guys
I'm like no you are the mindless masses
providing cover for the insanity yeah
because what happens is when you all
band together and start demanding that a
company bends the knee then the
extremists come in and say see that mob
they're with us do what we say or else
and then the company's okay okay okay
okay
definitely so you end up with that
Sheraton hotel owner graciously giving
up his building and all these companies
we're with you with you keep buying our
products keep buying our products yeah
that's all I'm saying
you know what worries me these people
who are getting cancelled and banned
they're not just going to wither up and
you know die they need money somehow
yeah the people get banned from social
media Alex Jones he made his own website
yeah so you're going to create parallel
systems it's true you know and then
you're gonna end up with people finding
resources through other means and then
you have no ties and nothing holding
anyone back the funny thing about all
the social media bannings and and the
firing like Rosanne getting fired in
these staffers getting fired is that if
they really wanted to they could use
that say give an apology and we'll make
it a PSA and then we're good to go
instead it's like now we're gonna get
rid of you forever that's a mistake yeah
that will that will cost them power so
these people who are apologizing a lot
of people think it's a struggle session
it's like what they used to do in the
Chinese you know revolution communist
revolution they would make the people
confess to sins they didn't commit okay
and then like humiliate them in public
oh that's weird because I actually read
an article about that today or I saw a
headline about that's exactly what they
do in the Chinese prison camps still
they give you a list of crimes to pick
off of and when you commit yet or you
commit to like pleading guilty and
that's that you're you're in this is
where we're at now they will come for
you and the scary thing is no one is
safe now so right now it's an
inquisition
we had canceled culture this was the
budding the growth now it's a literal
Inquisition where people are getting
purged they're hunting them down
everyone regular people okay listen
cancel culture for a while annoyed a lot
of people they would find a celebrity
and then find a tweet they post in about
ha now you have Twitter accounts where
they literally go to random like high
school girls mm-hm and they're like you
know to do we're exposing them no now
it's even worse it's way worse I'm
seeing this now it's it's being spread
around what you do is you take a picture
you you go on the person's page you find
a picture of them put some text you fake
it fake post it look at what this person
said cancelled yeah it's been going on
it's it's happening right now yep so
it's lies welcome you think position
general comes next hmm yeah what does
come next Cassandra Fairbanks posted on
Twitter the audio of the 9-1-1 call
where she said where she's crying with
her daughter saying there's people
shooting guns at my house and fireworks
that's yeah and then they come to your
house and so right now in New York they
are they have given immunity to black
lives matter protesters not even kidding
they straight-up said if you if you are
protesting for black lives matter you
will not be charged with a crime crime
related to the protesting low-level so
if you're looting or rioting or
something but they bait so if you
basically go out commit a low-level
offense and you're a churchgoer oh sorry
you know we favor we favor one ideology
this is how it starts in Fort Worth they
they specifically stated all of the
people arrested on rioting charges will
have their charges dropped rioting
charges not protesting Wow
dude the rioters success in Fort Worth
I'm not surprised
no siree and now we're seeing all these
companies bend over backwards look man
the dominoes are falling over it doesn't
matter what the well-to-do liberals say
about the bad seeds and the bad eggs no
it's all happening all right so if we're
gonna assume that dominoes keep falling
over what happens next
we're getting dangerously close to a
point where an angry mob shows up to
your house and the cops say it's easier
to arrest you than to deal with the mob
so let's say you salute you live in a
small town
your small town has ten cops on duty
okay and a mob of 300 people come from
outside your town show up at your house
what are those ten cops gonna do nothing
and so they say sorry can't help you and
then you get beaten and dragged under
the street and strung up that's why
these these companies are bending over
backwards because I want to deal with
it's like I've been saying man therefore
they know auntie foe will show up with
bricks and and fire bombs and they know
that the right won't so they're scared
to the left and they all bent over
backwards for them and now they have
massive institutional power so we may
see because of all of this weird fringe
culture revolution stuff a horrified
suburbanite demographic voting for
Republicans and Trump and droves I don't
think that's necessarily gonna change
anything
a lot of Republicans did literally
nothing when they had all branches of
the government yeah
not only that some of them agree and
they don't like Trump you still have
never you know you have a small faction
of Republicans who think Trump is an
insurgent and they don't like him yeah
so it's not a guarantee lot of Democrats
that go and deplorable Democrat to
deplorable you know I'm just saying we
don't cluded we don't know exactly what
will happen it could be that a lot of
people are just not paying attention and
don't care yeah and then the Democrats
win and take over and then these things
get steamrolled through at such rapid
speed if the Democrats in New York are
willing to give immunity if the Fort
Worth is willing to drop riding charges
there they are granting ideological
they're giving privilege to their
ideological group well if you're not
part of that they will come to you and
they will drag on the street put you on
your knees and say convert you know join
us and if you say no then you get locked
up or worse and I don't know if /one
that'll happen but I'll tell you this
man I didn't think they were to show up
exonerees house as fast as they did was
first it was the same day I watched her
tweets I follow her and I I was I was
even I was like okay well your your kind
of goat in the mock right now she go to
them
she was trolling she trolled them to no
end yep and it's and they showed up at
her house I'm not I'm not condoning it
but it's like I wasn't surprised that
they targeted her yeah yeah yeah yeah in
this country you're not allowed to shoot
at people's houses right you have a
right to free speech
they say crazy things yep and it's all
going away it is so you think about what
happened at the riding in New York when
I reference this guy's tweet where he
said he called the police and the police
said our city is under attack what would
you have us do what do what you got to
do so yeah it's gonna come to a point
where a mob shows up and you call the
cops and they're like there's 300 people
what do you want us to do oh I hope you
armed yourself and you're protecting
yourself I don't think the average
person has to worry about it but I also
think we have a serious problem with
regular people not standing up yeah and
they're scared of being canceled but the
more you don't speak up the more they
think they control things and the more
companies bend over and more resources
they gain they are they're counting on
your refusal to speak up for what you
believe in now many people may secretly
go and vote for Trump I think that only
make it worse you know why because these
people are so convinced that they're the
majority and they're right and the polls
reflect it that certainly if Trump wins
he must have cheated and so then what do
you think are gonna do revolt yeah
they're gonna be like it's he cheated
it's not real they're gonna challenge
him in the Supreme Court the Supreme
Court might flip you know they it might
roll in favor of them they all know we
saw what happened in North Jersey with
that with the voter fraud stuff the
mail-in voting 3,000 votes being is
qualified yeah all it takes is for them
to say look at the lines and Atlanta
like they've been doing oh no the lines
are so long now that we couldn't fairly
vote Trump cheated we must have the
Supreme Court remove him yeah I saw a
video a OC was pushing for mail-in
voting yep it's like no at first the
reason for Melon voting was confident
now that kovat is over what are they
saying oh it's because of long voting
lines they keep because they just want
to get it so make it a national holiday
to vote hello why are we doing that if
you want if you want if you want to
change the rules I say you do it after
the election you don't do an election
year boom because that's what they're
doing yeah they're trying to miss the
game yeah five months before exactly
that's insane absolute insanity absolute
insanity so you know what man you for
those are listening go watch
documentaries in the Spanish Civil War a
lot of crazy similarities you know when
you I was reading tweets from somebody
saying that George Orwell had spent time
in the SOPA Spanish Civil War I guess I
don't know that's true but it was in it
was
response it was a response to Majid
Nawaz who tweeted the quote from 1984
that the streets had been renamed the
statues had been renamed you know
history has been stopped we're seeing
all this now statues are being pulled
down you know streets are literally
being renamed in New York City they're
actually renaming streets they're gonna
take down a bunch of statues across the
country some of them I kind of roll my
eyes at like you know it's kind of dumb
we had these stages in the first place
but the way they're doing it is
lawlessness you know they show up in the
middle of then you know while now
they're sunk in the middle of the day
they used to go put you up the middle of
the night and now they're just all dance
and sing as they tear it down and
democracy be damned
they don't care I guess we'll see how
things play out huh but I'll tell you
what I say that all the time yes yeah I
always do i say this because i always
say here's how things can happen I guess
we'll see and guess what
I've been decently correct on what we
could expect yeah I will only hold on to
2018 as proof that Tim is not always
right because he makes some pretty scary
predictions I'm just hanging on to that
midterm election from 2018 I think it
was yeah I didn't consider that trumps
base wouldn't turn out yeah yeah there's
some things you just can't account for
until happens which I don't I don't
think I don't think my predictions are
always right right that is why you say
we'll see how it plays out
I hope I'm wrong about Hillary being the
VP I don't think so but I didn't just
said today I don't know if you know this
everyone Biden just said today that we
need a strong VP the one I choose needs
to be ready to be President on day one
he's gonna drop dead yeah during the
inauguration what president running for
president says that what kind of
president they're gonna coherently he's
gonna be you know they're gonna be doing
the inauguration he's me standing there
they're like put your hand in the Bible
he's gonna go he's put his put he's
gonna put his right hand up that his
left hand is gonna go and he falls over
Oh No
well I don't know thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. if you want
to catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon
have this podcast up for free on all
podcast platforms thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all in the next
episode
you